l'impur surprise hier
[Applaudissements]
latéraux surprise
isabelle si vous répondez bien si vous
avez la moyenne tout se passera bien si
vous répondez mal pendant la pub sur
facebook live les shérifs vous danserez
sur toutes les musiques de fort boyard
qu'elle est belle sexy j'ai envie
d'aller fouiller les poubelles regardant
les choses je vous jure isabelle morini
bosc est de plus en plus mon délire oui
non mais ça l'enjeu sais pas si c'est
moi qui arrive vers toi isabelle je te
le jure je te compte de plus en plus
belle il ya un truc de regarder je me
dis c'est vraiment une belle merde quoi
oui bien sûr c'était monstrueux il va
avoir un bail entre nous fussions c'est
à dire et vous êtes au bout du rouleau
avec tout ce que tu as pris comme uv
dans la gueule à laisser les séries
première question dans quelle émission
religieuse mine at il eu un énorme fou
rire avec nathalie baye michel roy du
fou rire mais c'est le roi du fou rire
alors avec nathalie maillet ouais non
maintenant matin bonheur très bonnes
réponses
[Applaudissements]
matin bonheur c'était énorme ça fou rire
incontrôlable tout livier olive et en
avait plein de marques est fatigué aussi
mais non c'est pas qu'on était fatigués
c'est qu'on n'était pas encore tout à
fait réveillé
ouais ça et cela 10 sur les séquences
sais pas si vous avez pas s'exprimer sur
un second side nathalie ce cas très
étrange c'est que l'émission s'appelait
matin bonheur et que depuis qu'elle
était arrivée sur le plateau les
séquences qui se succédaient n'était que
sur les plis qui sentent mauvais les
sécheresse vaginale est pivotable et
fait de spécial mais je n'ai pas les
battre agen après des combats coûteux
vérifier fait mais parce qu'olivier
crois qu'on est tellement pauvre il a
dit je ne sais pas si vous avez les
directives sepa
je suis saignée mons et connaissez
peut-être des morts sur ces huit têtes
ils n'ont pas acheté les images beaucoup
cher nathalie dans notre grande série
des déglingués
[Rires]
nous allons maintenant passer commencé
mardi matin les larmes de constipation
ballonnements presse pitié maintenance
et mais l'offensé ménopause
c'est la ménopause y arrivera et ya une
aura qui me dit olivier minne c'est le
plus gentil du monde je les aime
tellement c'est un grand monsieur frérot
emblavements brasse le pour moi or une
émission je t'appelle demain on se voit
bordel donc c'est bien une aura voilà
donc mais c'est vrai que je te jure t
tout le monde dit que tu es l'animateur
le plus sympathique du paf tueur c'est
vrai qu'ils remontent m6 alors c'est
louche
non mais je te jure que ça me touche ça
me touche je m'énerve pas soit insulté
comme olive et je te jure que c'est vrai
que tout le monde t'aime mais nous ça me
ça me touche parce que tu es sympathique
t naturelles ont fait bah on essaie tu
me prends pas la tête tu fais la télé tu
cliff et puis voilà c'était sympa
travail avec les deux films on est très
épris olivier est quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de répartie
grâce à ce que voyais aussi à la télé il
l'a aussi dans la vraie vie et c'est
très original
les métaphores que tu utilises les
tournures de phrases vraiment c'est ya
une poésie un humour ans la maison c'est
à la progressé depuis miss france elle
ses dires métaphore maintenant
[Applaudissements]